bubbles clowns and music in the Janine
refugee camp where two weeks ago the
sounds of bombs and bullets filled the
air
the children are excited to head to an
Arts therapy workshop with the local
Freedom theater
entertaining people on the way
with brushes at the ready they begin
[Music]
here to release the energy inside us
because of the Israeli occupation
when a child drew a house he
deliberately drew the window higher when
we asked him why he replied he feared
bullets entering the house other
children in the camp who live under
repeated aggression draw zigzags and
dark colors
this girl also adds Windows high up in
the house
these paintings are part of a series of
drama therapy workshops to tackle the
fear and Trauma children here are living
through the director tells me although
they're clearly having a lot of fun
today some are still too traumatized to
speak
some have messages to share after the
Israeli assault on Janine earlier this
month
after the invasion there have been
people in shock panicked with colors we
came to make them feel better through
painting in which they can express
what's inside them and we are also
expressing what is inside us
organizers say art can often expose a
cry for help
we have staff that work in sociology
psychology and social services that
visit families in the event of a raid we
hold group meetings to talk about
feelings and how the children can
express themselves through ART these
drawings are studied and we look at
cases where we need to intervene fast
for now they're getting the help they
need the fear of another assault is not
far away and some are seizing the moment
enjoying being who they are children
Laura Khan Al Jazeera Janine refugee
camp in the occupied West Bank